[Applause]
[Music]
all right
the misha pirates family how are you
dolly good to see you i'm baby sherry
harry sweetheart yeah
you and i are outnumbered big boy yes
three divas against two talented cooks
yes yeah basically we're [ __ ] yes
meet tonight's brigade the misha paris
family
sol diva misha
is joined by big sister paula a
hairdresser
these two love to cook almost as much as
they love to fight
dad trevor a retired chauffeur worked as
a chef in his 20s can he still cope with
the fast pace of a professional kitchen
and mum cherry a retired secretary
claims he's never messed up a meal let's
hope it stays that way
there's no room for divas this family
must pull together if they're going to
get out 50 perfect dishes
okay i'm going to show you how to do the
starter yes pan fried fillet of mackerel
on a warm potato salad mackerel a little
seasoning
salt and pepper
okay good right nice hot pan
okay
macrolint okay get that nice and crispy
it'll curl up naturally just put your
fingers
on and then after about 30 seconds they
start to release the fibers and then
just settle back down always cook
mackerel skin side first 90 of the
cooking will take place on its skin yeah
we cook it and turn it over it gets dry
very very quickly mackerel is officially
unique pink you have a total man you can
eat it raw you can you know marinate it
so be very very careful when it
overcooks it gets very very dry okay
potatoes in
the potatoes have been part board and
all you're doing is getting a little bit
color in the pan sour cream a little
teaspoon of some mustard yeah mix the
mustard
in
okay put salt and pepper on the potato
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah definitely
potatoes in
okay spring onions mix it up
with the sour cream of the mustard and
what you want is a really nice sort of
light mustard warm potato salad a little
touch of chardonnay vinegar yeah it just
wakes everything up a little bit gives a
nice sharp contrast to the richness of
the sour cream okay mackerel out nicely
colored literally finish it on top
sourdough nice and crispy yeah on
potatoes
you got the crisp mackerel
no nice
okay
and look just to make sure that they
don't slide all over the place take a
little spoon put that on there
and that just stops it from sliding yeah
our lambs lettuce again just gently on
the seasoning
a little touch of salt pepper
and a little glaze the heat of olive oil
once it's dressed give it a little bit
of green
okay very very simple
have a little taste all right very nice
that's great
oh that's so lovely okay concentrate on
all the four covers have a nine four
micro
trevor we'll do those two twos as a
fortune yes yes sir you've gotta put two
more in here football's gonna be a long
night holy [ __ ] yes
harry put your crystal away
okay put your crystals away
i'll put them away
i got to eat something decent tonight
you are going to get fed
thank
you're taking really long with the
potatoes girlfriend come on guys good
that's it nice right let's do a plate
each a little bit of salad around the
outside hey pete what you need to do
right get this ready you need to get the
salt and pepper
yeah yeah yeah potatoes don't you told
me for the bite of salt trevor okay
here to cook you not to watch now are
you happy with those i've loved it would
you pay for them i would pay them good
very nice
let's go on to the hot plate let's go
for six please jose now we're doing four
more yes
here's a food skill i've always wanted
to learn
i love chinese food but there's one
amazing delicacy so specialized that few
western chefs have ever mastered it so
today i'm off in search of some eastern
culinary wisdom
this is chinese dim sum an absolute
staple eating for breakfast lunch every
day and for the first time i'm gonna
learn how to cook them properly but
under immense [ __ ] pressure
dim sum means touch the heart and it's
easy to see why
[Music]
here at london's royal china club they
serve a vast array of beautiful
intricate little dumplings and rolls
from regions all over china
[Music]
what began as a simple chinese snack has
evolved over thousands of years into big
business all over the world
[Music]
helping me to demystify the ancient
world of dim sum is chinese cookery
expert fuchsia dunlop
this is one of the dim sum that
sometimes westerners find a bit more
tricky because it has that slithery
texture which chinese gourmet is really
a door to eat
i'm used to being boss of the kitchen
but as a dim sum virgin today i'm happy
to be the pupil
here we have the main kitchen area okay
no these guys are very small do you mean
petite but look at the space i mean it's
it's my new behind here yeah and it's
like an inferno when all the walks are
going
[ __ ] and this one here for steaming the
dim sum right so you can have a stack
okay on top
later my challenge will be to get
through a busy service at this top
london dim sum restaurant
but with just a couple of hours before
lunch i've got a hell of a lot to learn
[Music]
for now i've been put under the expert
guidance of zhang if anyone can speed
teach me this incredible art he's my man
in his 20 years as a dim sum chef he'll
have made well over two million of these
tricky little parcels
but there's one small problem so it
doesn't spaghetti english at all no i'm
screwed then nothing at all hello good
morning
no i'm [ __ ] okay
luckily future's on hand to translate
his instructions
good to see you
so is this rice flour
my first lesson is how to make a prawn
filled potato flour dumpling called
hagao
[Music]
hold in
[Music]
just like pasta the secret to good dim
sum is as much about the wrapper as the
filling that's what's going to hold all
the flavor and moisture in
hard
cheese
unlike an italian kitchen there are no
pasta machines in sight
[Music]
jesus
so he's using the palm of his hand
my god
[ __ ]
they're beautiful huh
they're so soft
jung made it look easy
now it's my turn
okay use this the finger of this hand to
push it this your index finger
look so you're holding this and just
pinching but you push it with that
finger
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah
saying that it didn't sound particularly
difficult because of all this fine
finger work and you have to be a bit
kind of calm and patient calm and
patient yeah i'm screwed straight away
right
calm on patients
i can't remember being this nervous in
the kitchen
and as any pastry chef will tell you hot
sweaty hands are not what you need with
all this delicate work
it's so intricate
so difficult jesus christ
they're extraordinary
that is a lot [ __ ] harder than it
looks i tell you such intricacy
and if i thought that was difficult i
hadn't bargained on jung's next lesson
chung fun paper thin cheese a rice and
potato flour batter wrapped around a
choice of fillings
it's really hot so the most important
thing with this is not to be afraid of
scolding your hands in the steam right
after just three minutes the skin
scorching paper thin sheets of batter
are ready to be rolled
sticking to the clock like [ __ ] to a
blanket
i haven't felt this clumsy since i first
set foot in a kitchen 20 years ago
[Applause]
the real killer is to wrap the filling
tightly without splitting it
okay
[ __ ] me that was hard i mean seriously
hard very intricate it's all in the
manipulation of the dough
with training over next will be put to
the test under hard as nails henry
chao the kitchen's head chef i'm told
he's every bit as tough as me
knows what service is
[Music]
i'm trying to [ __ ] get there get rid
of that [ __ ] all right
see that was the problem you know what
the problem was that was trying to help
me oh stop trying to blame me for it do
you know what happened take your own
responsibilities love you if i wasn't
watching her i would have done the math
whatever
your heart uh cherry i wish your
daughters were working as quick as you
two yes
look at them right misha can you do
something yes
no so you get the salad now i'm dressed
as salad hey did you do that
yeah right good come on come on come on
come on guys diva are you happy with
those
let me see okay yeah yeah i'm all right
with it i'm not too crazy about those
two i'll be straight because it's curled
up is that where i i'm glad you answered
the div at least you know see you got me
again
service
[ __ ] hell
last table well done
i really enjoyed it the mackerel itself
was quite simple but you get the kick
from the mustard and the spring onion
afterwards
really live and dish up visually it
looked really great it's lovely green
sort of color coloring and the yellow
was you know from the potatoes was great
um so yeah it worked really well
okay jose results please
okay
the number of diners that are willing to
pay for the starter is oh [ __ ]
45 out of 15.
[Applause]
unbelievable now
that is [ __ ] good news yeah well done
thank you may calls let's get 50 out of
50 yeah yes clear down get on your
stations let's go
coming up the brigade attempt to cook
pigeon breast with a summer vegetable
casserole either way [ __ ] hell
but things fall apart
now we're just going down like a [ __ ]
dog dinner
[Music]
[Applause]
right sherry gass up yes let's go good
girl we're on chef welcome back to the f
word time for the main course
[Music]
pigeon breast with a summer vegetable
casserole one of my favorite birds very
lean and very healthy
salt
pepper
hot pan
olive oil
pigeon breast skin side down first
turn
the most exciting thing about cooking
pigeons they cook in minutes
rest
[Applause]
garnish for the casserole a nice
alternative to potatoes a puff pastry
floor on
puff pastry
cut your holes and then cut them in half
again until you've got this really nice
sort of
half moon shape
egg wash
salt
thyme
200 degrees
in
we're serving the pigeon casserole with
a combination of delicious and summery
vegetables
smoked pancetta
give the pancetta a really nice color
garlic
that looks quite sort of autumnal
this is a summery part asparagus
baby carrots
baby leeks blanche
beetroot
[Music]
[Applause]
the colours are that beautiful
red wine vinegar we're going to delay
that down to a syrup which it starts to
coat the vegetables
chicken stock tarragon
broad beans
beautiful
for the summer
the smoked pancetta has given body to
the vegetable casserole but the flavors
in there are extraordinary
slide the pigeon in half
and you'll see the color of the pigeon
there nice and pink
[Applause]
small drizzle of olive oil
puff pastry case on
top pigeon with a summer vegetable
casserole
done
come on
50 now come on now
paula yes i love this hand on hook shake
shake shake
jesus christ yes
so they come out
yeah we rest them skin side up red wine
vinegar in
let that reduce down
bye paula yeah get your pigeons in let's
go two portions each
the idea is to colour them not cremate
them
trevor yeshua we are there
beautiful nice and pink
very very nice trevor you're happy with
that
yeah sure good man make them all like
that now
thank you very much
done five
um [ __ ] hands
down
why have you done five all right
manhattan i need the juice i need the
juice
right now look at me look paula come
here i've got one and a half i've only
got three bits of pigeon there i've got
two pieces of pigeon there four bits of
pigeon there one two three four and five
bits there come on guys we're seriously
letting ourselves down
now no no no come here oh nice holy [ __ ]
what do you want to do [ __ ] floss
with it jesus christ almighty
[Music]
watch out genesee porter's getting
fruity
smoothies heavenly fruit-filled drinks
mango and passion fruit raspberry
coconut and banana
the perfect way to get your five a day
what you've got to be joking who writes
this rubbish
my goodness we love smoothies don't we
in fact we drink so much of the ruddy
stuff it could fill 14 olympic swimming
pools in a year that's almost 60 million
pints
personally i can't stand smoothies but
you lot seem to think they're a healthy
antidote to 21st century excess
but are they if anyone bothered to read
the labels they might be surprised to
find out what they're really drinking
a typical 250 ml portion is packed with
natural sugar a portion of this smoothie
has twice the sugar and twice the
calories as this kind of tango
[Music]
this smoothie has got just as much sugar
in it
as this chocolate bar
[Music]
now this smoothie has got twice as much
sugar and twice as much calories as
this kind of lil
[Music]
it's not all bad news smoothies do
contain vitamin c and many contain fiber
too essential for a healthy digestive
system
but what about the natural sugars
i want to hear the facts from kath
collins an expert dietitian i've never
ever ever drunk smoothie to me they're
like green slurry they're hugely popular
well they are because they count towards
you five a day and everyone knows you
should be eating more fruit and veg and
they're a good source of fiber actually
they do contribute fibre the problem is
they're full of sugar i thought it was
natural sugar sugar is sugar it has the
same calorie load same effect on your
teeth if you have an apple you've got
about 10 grams of sugar in that
if you're having a smoothie you can be
having three times in one little drink
you can swallow that in less than a
minute and that's the problem it's just
so much sugar in a very small volume
taking a very short period of time what
happens when you drink too many
smoothies if you're in energy balance
the amount of calories you're eating
from your daily diet is the same as the
amount your body needs if you have an
extra smoothie each day it's giving you
at least 125 calories and over a year
that'll be almost an extra stone in
weight 13 14 pounds they're not a low
calorie drink and it is actually better
to eat the fruit than it is to buy a
smoothie
it's official drinking to excess isn't
good for you oh it looks disgusting
this is certainly not going to convert
me i've had enough of this trendy
obsession with drinking fresh fruit i'm
on a mission to tell people it's far
better for you just to eat it
now to really make my point i've got
here this repulsive fake ass
now this weighs 13 pounds and that is
the amount of weight you could put on in
a year if you drank one extra smoothie
every single day than your body actually
needed so let's try lifting it
help come here
drink one smoothie a day in addition to
your normal calorie intake and you could
put on weight but do people know this if
they're not exercising enough to burn
off their excess sugar they could be
lumbered with a fat ass like mine
one portion of that
has got more sugar than that no
did you know that no not at all i'd
always think that like a smoothie would
be much better if you did a fizzy drink
wow
let's say you're uh he's seven thirteen
pounds
i'll be doing any running in there
what does it feel like bit heavy
gross i drink these because like they're
meant to be good for you
the fruit is better i don't want that
bottom
just hold this bottom just try it this
is from smoothies
yeah that's quite shocking actually when
you eat an apple yeah it tastes twice as
long to eat as sloping down that
smoothie do you know how much weight you
put i just drink once
oh yeah just like your size isn't it
what do you mean just like mine
right get rid of him
i'm going to give you a smoothie and
buckle off now
well i think i've made my point with
that horrible big ass and i hope very
much that the commuters of london will
now drink less smoothies and try eating
a few more of these there's only one old
smoothie that i've got left to convince
janet
i've been taking smoothies out and
trying to convert people to drink
less smoothies and eat more real fruit i
love smoothies what's wrong with them so
how many do you eat and what are they
one a day you're done no seriously it's
a good job you're hyperactive are they
seriously that full of sugar they ask
for a lot of natural sugar fructose
which is still sugar yeah so you're
saying eat fresh fruit instead of a
smoothie yeah i can see you're wearing
that rubber ass it's sushi it makes that
joke i've got the rubber ass oh you've
got it
although we had it on this is the rubber
outsole
okay oh
still that is what gordon's ass is going
to look like if he carries on having a
smoothie a day for a year and if you
stop running marathons god help you
because that's what your bum's going to
do that looks like a pair of boobs god
not that high up no no it's a simon
cowell i'm gonna let it go down it's
gonna sag like everything at 60.
[Applause]
you'd look nice with a nice firm buttock
like that janet janet don't forget your
ass janet
sherry yeah now the pigeons burnt up me
watch out yeah they're burnt they're
[ __ ] burnt yeah when they're brown
yeah they cook when they're black
they've popped yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] in hell now we're just going down
like a [ __ ] dog dinner niche yes
don't go sulky and don't give up no i
don't give up let's go please
why did you do that because it was
burning
okay then
nice bumpy
okay
right sherry yeah table of four yeah
good girl trevor yeah table of four yeah
coming up blue on just cut the top
basically please sherry trevor i'm
loving you well done yeah
thank you one talented dad misha paris
let's go cute man
right now look at me look this is such a
shame i've got all the fat still in the
larls
look yeah
[Music]
that's the story of tonight
right how are we very welcoming good
nice to see you how was the picture
with it i think we all sort of thought
it was very very salty and damn salty
what a shame well it was a brown chicken
stock so it was sort of there to act as
a bit of a broth
almost like a little bit of it was
almost misnamed if it had been uh pigeon
summer vegetables with a jew maybe
[Laughter]
the tarragon's fantastic really came
through um really fresh licoricey flavor
the pigeon was cooked really well crispy
on the outside tender in the middle i
thought it was very flavoursome it was
quite a strong um taste
and yeah it was really lovely
right jose
the amount of customers are gonna pay
for the main course out of fifty
35 out of 50.
[Applause]
let's get 50 out of 15. yes the top
reserved on the sections let's get going
i'm feeling great i thought but it's a
bit hot in the kitchen but i feel you
know i could go again we always bicker
you know but it's it's so harmless it's
just a sister thing you know it's like
music
well that's because she's the younger
one so she's always trying to prove a
point
don't tell her i told you
who is that each other one knows the
best the other one knows the best you
know everyone knows the best
and they never know nothing
next on the menu i've been taught the
basics of how to make dim sum now the
pressure's really on as i'm thrown into
service coming now he's worse than me
now [ __ ] you know that
my brigade make a delicious strawberry
glory and the squabbling siblings call a
truce yeah i'm sorry now yeah right kiss
makeup yes
and joe brand brings a vegetarian flavor
to the recipe challenge why are you
doing a veg curry well because if it
doesn't taste nice enough i'll just chop
up a vegetarian and put them in
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to the f word uh
now it's time for the recipe challenge
with internationally acclaimed
supermodel me
come on in okay what are you doing i'm
doing a veg curry oh come on chad you
love the vegetarian yeah i do when
they're fast asleep
why are you doing a veg curry well
because if it doesn't taste nice enough
i'll just chop up a vegetarian and put
them in now that i like the sound off
right when was the last time you
practiced the dish oh about 1947.
is it this may be rationing
uh it was yes right vegetable curry uh
joe's doing a classic and what's the
ingredients just quickly run through and
tell me what they are that's an onion
you've seen one before
yes and something rather uh scary uh
you've been in demia's cupboard what is
that a jar of what that it's a balti
curry paste you lazy bugger huh well
what's wrong with being lazy
just gonna chop up some garlic and a bit
of ginger and put that in as well joe
to my horror bought in a curry paste so
easy to make coriander seeds poppy seeds
turmeric garlic ginger and chili powder
into a pesto mortar then from their
tablespoon of ground oil and then just a
tablespoon of white wine vinegar that
forms a really nice paste
and it's ten times tastier than anything
no it's really nice
i know it tastes delicious i've made it
before
you do a lot of cooking at home don't
you yeah just cooking that is simple and
doesn't take very long so i can go and
practice my other hobby which is being
an alcoholic so
now you've got two beautiful little
girls yeah
yes yeah maisie and eliza eliza lovely
how old are they one's 43 and the other
two
seriously how old are they five and
seven five or seven what do you cook at
home i do a very nice haribo stew which
they like and then i give them chocolate
um that's the main course lovely lovely
kittens you know they must love you
on tour yes
i like a nice pork pie when i'm on tour
yeah anything you can get in a garage
that is made by ginsters always does me
a treat
you know what you just made me feel even
more confident about winning you know
that
i've i've browned my onions and then
i've put some pepper and some aubergine
in i'm just gonna dice up some potato
and some cauliflower and bang that in uh
most daunting gig ever was when
well i think it was probably a gig that
i did up in um
bolton in a working men's club yep
and as one they all shouted [ __ ] off
your fat leather as they went on
and it's true in the early days the
lessons used to complain about it give
them a bad reputation right over the
years they've signed petitions and sent
them to me telling me to tell everyone
i'm heterosexual because it's giving
lesbians a bad reputation
okay
swept the aubergines and the slots down
first garlic chilies take the heat out
of them in with the broccoli and the
cauliflower peppers
all right
i'm now grating some lard
see that's my secret ingredient lard all
right it's coconut it's coconut it's
quite a jazzy curry this thing you know
huh is it well it sounds it you're from
scotland aren't you yeah and they're
very healthy there aren't they
because i always used to think with
scotland you know they've got the
highest rate of heart disease in europe
which means you get decent grab there
you've lost a lot of weight
i've lost a bit of weight are training
or was it through diet you know i
trained for the marriage
thank christ i had a virus the week
before so i'm going to do it yeah and
all that training or should i i
shouldn't say christ on tellyx people
get upset [ __ ]
were you looking forward to running the
mountain
well what i wasn't looking forward to
was dying in front of thousands of
people because i thought i might because
i'm a fat person i was a fat chef once
17 and a half stone in fact just under
18 stone when i ran my first marathon
wow it was a [ __ ] nightmare i got
back it was dark the family [ __ ] off
home and i was picking cones up on the
way home see that's the thing i was
worried about because i estimated my
time during the marathon
at about 12 and a half hours you could
do it within 12 hours joe come on do you
reckon oh yeah
curry paste in little handful of
coriander rolled up and just fry off the
coriander finish with a touch of garlic
some chopped tomatoes up to the boil and
let it cook out what does this cook out
the raw they're all paste um curry paste
yeah it's very tart because it's all
very uh raw so raw garlic raw ginger
um cook it out let it mellow can i come
and have a look at you you can come have
a look at mine now he's sort of
disintegrated and that looks like
something you get out of a heinz tin
come back and joe loses as simple as
that
right back to dim sum and it's time for
service
in my quest to learn how to make dim sum
i'm about to be thrown in at the deep
end at the royal china club in london
[Music]
this place can do over 200 covers and
like any head chef worthy salt the
uncompromising henry chow expects his
brigade to jump on the orders as soon as
they come on
trouble is they're all in chinese
do you understand that what is that
something you have that says the fresh
and shrimp chunk fresh
[Music]
[Music]
i've never been in a kitchen where i've
never been in control so this is really
[ __ ] weird
but icy cool head chef henry is in
control he's clearly a man after my own
heart
he won't let a mortal leave his kitchen
unless it's absolutely perfect
understandably he's watching his most
recent recruit like a hawk
so will my first effort pass muster with
my tough new master
coming now hello
i'm determined to get some of my dim sum
past henry and out to the diners
[Music]
i may be an award-winning chef but as
soon as i'm sending plates out they're
coming back
can someone go for the soup and give the
dumpling a rest
i think fuchsia's enjoying this a lot
more than i am
they're too small
it's a pleasure to learn a new skill but
i hate getting a bollocking even in
translation
[Music]
with service nearly over it's my last
chance to achieve dim sum perfection
[ __ ] it out he's worse than me that
[ __ ] you know that huh
jesus christ
he's happy with that last one yes
yeah excellent happy
yeah good
thank me thanks for that
jesus christ
[Music]
that was [ __ ] phenomenal really tough
to begin with and very intricate who
would have thought that you're spending
three pound four pound fifty for a bowl
of [ __ ] dim sum and they're all made
by hand extraordinary just goes to prove
that [ __ ] chinese cookie's not all
about a wok [ __ ] hats off
working in henry's kitchen has really
inspired me and with lunch service out
the way i want to show him a dish of my
own
right gonna do a little uh dumping but
my may and see what the guys think
my chinese-style tortellini is based on
a mixture of prawns scallops and crispy
duck
the texture the scallop and the shrimp
together delicious
i'm hoping head jeff henry will be so
impressed he'll put it on his menu
pull that fat off
let me just chop that up
really nice combination
the duck
i'm adding finely chopped ginger garlic
and a squeeze of lemon juice
lemon juice in
okay coriander
finally some finely sliced mixed veg
texture
bring color in
keep it nice and hold so you can
identify it
right
so with these
i'm borrowing a few of john's expertly
flattened skins the scallop
really nip it together
little tortellinis
nice
very good okay we're steamed now yeah
four minutes
nice
that look good
so what does the dim sum master and his
brigade make of my duck and seafood
tortellini thank you
you like henry
what do you like
five hours five out of ten
little [ __ ]
five out of ten hey tell him there's no
msg in there either huh
jesus five out of ten from these guys is
high praise indeed in another 20 years
maybe i'll marry a six
so he's not going on a special tonight
tell him when he goes back to school
i'll take over okay
yeah
thank you very much thank you very
[Music]
[ __ ] sake now whip my cream up let's
go
this gorgeous it just came off by itself
guys that's the eject button yes that's
the on button oh that's right misha will
blame the apparatus
[Music]
strawberry glory a great way of
celebrating the best of british
strawberries
strawberries half
icing sugar
balsamic vinegar the combination of the
tartness of the vinegar against the
sweetness of the strawberries is
mind-blowing drizzle over the
strawberries icing sugar
pan nice and hot
strawberries in
caramelized 15 to 20 seconds a quick
toss then back out
creme patisserie commonly known as a
really nice thick custard milk cream
boil
egg yolks
sugar
whip whip
[Applause]
flour
take out one third of the cream of milk
stir once that's liquefied put all of
your milk and your cream in there
put it back in the pan bring the custard
up to the boil which will cause it to
get really nice and thick
[Music]
[Applause]
into the fridge to cool down
cream
icing sugar then over with the cream
just as it's starting to fall through
your whisk
get your thick custard
take off one third
whisk
the rest of it straight in
nice just
falling through the whisk now for the
exciting part putting this little baby
together
strawberries
juice
pastry cream crushed meringue
repeat
[Music]
a really nice board vanilla ice cream
sit there on top of the thick rich
custard
juice
grated chocolate
it wouldn't be complete
without one of these
a good old-fashioned british wafer
[Music]
strawberry glory
done
strawberries meringue cream strawberries
meringue cream ice cream chocolate wafer
yeah okay sprinkle the
sprinkle of chocolate on top well done
good off you go buddy
yeah if no one plays with this dessert
yeah they don't deserve the bean hit go
please go please come on go go let's go
yeah you with me yeah man i'm with you
man proper all right so there you go
that's another four yeah
the trevor they're wafers
wafers
wafers i'm gonna need a [ __ ] week in
the primary after this [ __ ] service
let's go
holy [ __ ]
what was the naughtiest thing you two
did when you're kids i know what she did
to me what was naughty go on one day
yeah i think i was about nine and she
stole my two pence do you remember that
i didn't steal it
she took my two pants but you don't
understand back then two pence was like
it was like 10 pounds when you were a
kid back then you know it was a lot of
money
[Music]
can i just tell him the story oh for
god's sake
in the door that was that oh what am i
tonight you
are gonna forgive her right now yeah i'm
sorry now yeah right kiss makeup yes
that's nice that's nice
and will you forgive her all right then
give it back right there give it back
give it back to your silly one
only two left let's go make these
perfect
right
let's go let's go let's go right off we
go last table you know what can i just
can i just say that i feel like a weight
has been lifted oh last time we'll show
you
trevor
well [ __ ] done oh yes
coming up will joe brand be laughing at
the results of the recipe challenge is
it gonna be joe brand or joe bland
harry enfield sorts out dessert now
mitch do you remember you're taking coke
you're on smack now
and we find out whether the brigade has
what it takes to come back to the f-word
restaurant for final service the number
of guests that are going to pay for
dessert
is
[Applause]
right welcome back to the f word and
time for the results of the recipe
challenge and for joe brand to
understand why you should never use a
bought in curry paste are you ready
now
this is the bit i seriously like side by
side you see mine looks delicious and
yours looks like it's out of a jar
that's very cheffy
josie come back with the right result
hey good luck yeah good luck
thank you
it's very mild though isn't it it's not
hot it's got not got a massive amount of
flavor to it next one
next okay
there's a lot more going on there
it tastes more like how do you think a
curry should taste as well isn't it yeah
a lot more flavor more flavor and it's
good after taste as well it's much more
of a punch
here we go how are you feeling first oh
very confident very confident yes is it
going to be joe brand or joe bland yeah
it was actually quite close right come
on they like both who's the winner
gordon you did yes
what was the
certainly a bit more overpowering on the
coriander i believe
this at the end i did put half a tree in
look at your face you're loving this
aren't you don't do a little dance on
the pass
yes excellent you know i hate losing
i've been waiting all day for that one
yes pretty good to see you thanks for no
thanks now [ __ ] off out of my kitchen
yeah
that's my kind of girl well done
excellent and did you manage to get your
tongue all the way down to the bottom no
i had to put my finger in
happy dinosaurs i'm so pleased are you
gonna pay for the dessert yeah
we'll pay for everything ladies it's
really good to see yes
it's extremely fresh it everything
complemented each other the juices were
gorgeous and the strawberries just
melted in your mouth
gentlemen good to see you
harry how are you hello welcome oh thank
you very much good to see you guys how
was dinner it was fantastic what do you
like about it uh the salt the salt is
transitioned
it's delicious because you're quite a
foodie right can't you tell i'm a foodie
i actually seduced my wife through food
oh seriously what did you get yeah well
it was something from a julia smith
yeah and it was
i remember it was cods and it had capers
and it was it was actually delicious
what was it a sort of cody capri thing
anyway i won her with that meal i've
never had to cook again she's a very
good cook that's nice you used to date
lily allen's
mum at one stage did you know she's
gonna be a potential star did you could
you see it at that age uh
she was always very clever yeah and and
very very very funny and slightly ahead
of the crowd she was in my show she's
like a kid on the neat you you know we
do the old kids yeah we'd scare a kid
and she'd be there yeah and amy
winehouse was in the fast show
quite cool you know recently you've been
involved in dramas
yes yes did you run out of jokes did you
go dry did you
did you oh no i just got asked to do
this skin thing i've done a bit of
directing and i got asked to do some of
that so i did a bit of that they're all
very good all the all the people in it
yeah they're all very good but they're
kind of young so it's a bit like being
a school teacher because they don't
really concentrate you know they're busy
with their own lives and doing what
they're doing so you have to go okay
okay kind yeah they're all come on
everyone what are we doing okay now
mitch do you remember you're taking coke
in this seat have you got your coke
have you have you got your line that's
out you're on smack now aren't you teddy
where is your smack you haven't got it
have you could we get this man there's
quite a lot of that goes on okay
please give me the results quickly i'm
[ __ ] myself yes
whatever happens i thought you did
bloody well yeah you're fast you're good
and more importantly you worked as a
team again yes
and one thing that came out of it you
are lovely tight-knit family well done
thank you really well then the number of
guests that i'm gonna pay for
desserts
is
44 out of 15.
that's
[Applause]
so a grand total
of 124 out of 150 well done
here's the good news sadly you're not
coming back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you